[Música]
una gigantesca autopista de hielo que
hay que rehacer y mantener cada año con
las gélidas temperaturas del invierno en
el norte de Canadá lagos y ríos se
congelan formando placas de hielo tan
gruesas que durante décadas Los
camioneros han confiado en esta ruta
para transportar sus mercancías pero un
clima más cálido provocado por la crisis
climática significa que un día estas
carreteras heladas podrían desaparecer
Álex lleva 30 años conduciendo por la
zona lleva equipos a las minas de
diamantes aún más al norte
llevamos todo a las minas camas comida
neumáticos todo el equipo grande
pasa 12 horas conduciendo por la
carretera helada no necesita neumáticos
especiales pero su camión no puede ir a
más de 25 kilómetros por hora solo hay
un metro de hielo entre este camión de
seis toneladas y las aguas heladas todo
depende del camión que tengas y de tu
peso solo puedes Conducir a cierta
velocidad si conduces demasiado rápido
rompes el hielo la carretera solo está
abierta tres meses al año pero es una
línea de su vital para las minas de
diamantes a cielo abierto en los
territorios del noroeste en 2021 la
minería y el sector del petróleo y el
gas representaron el 18% del pib
regional la minería es la fuente de vida
de la economía local pero los intentos
de diversificación han fracasado
esto ayuda a la economía mi hijo por
ejemplo trabaja en una de las minas de
diamantes
hacia las perforaciones y luego crea
puestos de trabajo para la gente que
abre estas carreteras y las mantiene
durante dos o tres meses
el gobierno local vigila continuamente
el estado de la carretera Alex Pacman
mide el grosor del hielo perforando la
capa el hielo debe tener un grosor
mínimo de 78 centímetros para que sea
seguro circular por él
aquí el hielo tiene 110 centímetros de
grosor
pero en los últimos años se ha visto
como el hielo se hace cada vez más fino
y las carreteras se abren más tarde de
lo usual antes se habrían a finales de
diciembre este año han tenido que
esperar hasta principios de febrero
he notado que la capa es menos homogénea
que antes en los años 50 y 60 se salía
el hielo y no se comprobaba realmente
solo se hacían uno o dos agujeros pero
ahora si haces eso corres el riesgo de
atravesar el hielo
el norte de Canadá Se está calentando
unas tres veces más rápido que el resto
del mundo esta zona está en la primera
línea de la crisis climática
[Música]
en 2000 o 2001 teníamos entre 70 y 80
días abiertos si miramos a 2020 hemos
bajado a 60 o 65 días y sigue bajando
creo que a finales de siglo no habrá
muchas más oportunidades para las
carreteras de hielo todavía puede haber
una oportunidad pero Será muy pequeña
el fin de la carretera de hielo
significaría también que decenas de
pueblos cercanos al Círculo Polar Ártico
podrían quedar incomunicados la mayoría
solo están conectados con el resto del
país durante los meses de invierno en
gameti una comunidad indígena de sólo
300 habitantes El combustible de los
alimentos y la infraestructuras Llegan
todos por carretera el resto del año el
pueblo solo es accesible por avión con
esta complicada mezcla de lagos ríos y
zonas de tierra es imposible Navegar en
barco hoy el alcalde se siente aliviado
por fin ha llegado una de sus entregas
estos son los postes necesarios para las
luces de la calle los pedimos en julio
del año pasado y estuvimos esperando a
que se abriera nuestra carretera helada
para que nos los entregaran
para nosotros es realmente un salvavidas
si no hay carretera de hielo esta
comunidad quedará técnicamente aislada
del resto del planeta
este año el acceso al pueblo solo estará
disponible un par de semanas durante el
periodo invernal entre las diez de la
noche y las 10 de la mañana el resto del
tiempo el hielo es demasiado frágil
los pedidos de mayor tamaño que llegan
por camión son el detergente en polvo y
los productos de limpieza
estoy tratando de ver si puedo conseguir
mis pedidos al por mayor para este
verano Y me preocupa tener que subir mis
precios para la comunidad
en un esfuerzo por financiar la mejora
del acceso a este tipo de asentamientos
remotos entre otros proyectos el
gobierno canadiense ha destinado casi
500 millones de euros a inversiones En
infraestructuras en estos territorios
del noroeste en los últimos seis años